FRANCESCO CROVETTO: Hi,
everyone, and welcome.
So my name is Francesco.
And I'm a business analyst
in the Google Play team.
And today we'll talk together
with Toby about influencers.
But let me start by
introducing one of them to you.
So his name is Yarn.
He's a YouTube
Gaming influencer.
And he has a channel called
Orange Juice Gaming with more
than one million subscribers.
So these people really
trust his gaming reviews.
And we are here today
together with Toby to tell you
more about the
value that we think
Yarn, as well as other
YouTube influencers like him,
can bring to your business.
So today we'll go
through three main areas.
The first one is about
the influencer opportunity
and challenges.
Then I will walk you
through a methodology
that we build
internally in Google
to measure the full value
of influencer marketing.
And then Toby will
finish by telling you
some best practices on how to
build a successful influencer
strategy going forward.
So we all know this
YouTube is a big thing.
And it is a big thing
on the youth side.
So what research says
is that 90% of gamers
turn to YouTube at
least once a week
to discover gaming content.
This gaming content could
be about advancement tips.
Maybe users are
stuck into a level
and want to know
how to get through.
It could be to watch their
favorite creator playing games
or to discover new games.
So definitely YouTube is a
big thing on the user side.
But what about on
the developer side?
Well, I'm sure that you
know from your business
that it is a big thing on
the developer side as well.
So game developers already today
spend more than $250 million
a year on influencer content.
And this number is
forecasted to grow
a lot in the next few years.
But that's what research says.
I'm actually curious to
know, within this room,
how many of you spent
on influencer content
in the past couple of years?
Please hands up.
Pretty much everyone.
And how many of you
are 100% confident
that the methodology
that you used
to evaluate the full
impact of these campaigns
is fully accurate?
One person.
OK.
We should talk afterwards.
I actually agree with you.
It's really, really tough
to measure the full impact
of influencer content.
And there is this big
industry attribution challenge
that I'm sure everyone
in this room faces.
So the way it works
today is that developers
would collaborate
together with creators.
Then these YouTube
creators or influencers
will produce a video, upload
the video into their channel,
and then include one of
these trackable links
in the description
underneath the video.
And then, obviously,
developers would
hope that all the users
who watch the video
and are interested
to download the game
do it by clicking on the
link so they can be tracked.
However, we all know that
this is not the case.
Some of the users
who watch the video
and still don't
know the game do it
without clicking on the link.
And so it's really hard to
understand what is the value
and what is the size of
this nontracked majority.
And so the classical ways
that developers use nowadays
to do that is to look at the
performance of the video,
look at how many people click on
the link and download the game,
and try to estimate
this key factor of users
who watch the video, didn't
click, but still download.
And how to do that?
You would usually look at
your install numbers over time
and try to estimate how
many of these users that you
see in these spikes are coming
through the video itself.
Well, that's a really
hard thing to do.
And it's even harder whenever
there is noise in the installs.
So try to imagine that you
just launched your game.
There would be a spike
in installs anyway even
without videos.
Or try to think that
you're running a paid
campaign at the same time.
How do you know how
much of these users,
this nontracked majority, is
coming from paid, organic,
or the video itself?
Well, let me spend
a minute to talk
about this nontracked majority.
Who are these users?
So these are people who
are watching the video
and deciding not to
click on the link
but still download the
game, or maybe they
didn't see the click the link.
It could be users who watch
the video, download the game,
but wait for Wi-Fi not
to use their whole data
plan while installing,
or it could be also
users watching the
video on PC and then
just grabbing the phone next
to them to download the game.
Does this sound familiar?
Great.
So we thought that
we, as Google, we
are in a unique
position to try to help
you to understand the
value and the size
of this nontracked majority.
And so we developed
a methodology
that I am really excited
to share with you today.
So what we did, we
combined the knowledge
that we have from YouTube,
meaning users watching videos,
and from Play, meaning the same
users then going on the store
and hopefully
installing the game.
And so with this
methodology, we have
been able to see out
of the cohort of users
who have been exposed, who
watched a YouTube gaming
video featuring a
particular game, how
many of these same
users after viewership
went into the Play Store
and downloaded the game.
And then we want to
go one step further
and try to understand what
is the value of these users.
So we also checked how many
of them turned into buyer.
And if they do, how much
they spend over time
after viewing the video.
And so then we use
this methodology
to analyze a pool of
more than 120 videos,
making up a total
of 50 million views.
And in order not to be
biased with the results
that we are going to
share with you today,
we took examples from
developers of all sizes, genre,
and with games at
different lifecycle stages.
And then we mix it up also
on the influencer side.
So we took examples
from micro as well
as more established influencers
and also from gaming
as well as nongaming
influencers.
And so I'm really excited
now to share with you some
of the insights that we have.
So let's jump into measuring
influencer and the key insights
that we have.
So we divided the insights
into two main buckets,
insights about
the gamers and how
we go through them, and then
insights about the influencers.
And Toby will come back
to talk to you about that.
So the gamers.
I'm sure that the question that
everyone is asking themselves
right now is we talked about
this nontracked majority,
how big it is.
Well, I'm very glad
to tell you today
that using our
methodology, we saw
that there are four 4x more
installs beyond the tracking
link.
That means that next time that
you do an influencer marketing
campaign, for every
person that you
see that watches the
video, clicks on the link,
and download the game,
you can expect on average
to have four more people who
do the same without clicking.
And by the way, 4x
is just an average.
This multiplier can
be as high as 10x
depending on the type of
content and the type of game
that the creator is featuring.
And so the follow
up question that we
had after that,
after understanding
how big is this
nonprofit majority,
is how does the distribution
of the install look
like over time?
Do they come all
at the same time?
Do they come after a few hours,
after a few, days, and so on.
And so what we saw
is that, on average,
50% of the install come within
the first hour after users
viewed the video on YouTube.
But then you may also
think, OK, but what
about if I want to know a good
attribution we know to capture
all the installs, not just 50%.
Then we saw that
after four days,
the installs start to be flat.
So users after the moment
when they watch the video,
it take about four days
to decide whether or not
to install the game.
So if you're not sure of
the attribution window
to use for your next
influencer marketing campaign,
then four days is a good one.
Second insight is about ripple
effect across your portfolio.
So similar games
will get it in stores
as well, even if they
are not shown or featured
in your video.
So what we saw is that for
an influencer marketing
campaign showing a particular
game in your portfolio,
let's call it game
A, then you can also
get installs in game
B in your portfolio
even if it was not shown
in the video itself.
So for every 10 people
who watched the video
and download the game A, there
is also one person on average
which would go one step
further and download also
game B from your portfolio.
And again, one out of
10 is just an average.
This multiplier can be as
high as three people out of 10
people depending on
the type of influencer
and also depending if the users
who installed the first game
in your portfolio
love it so much they'd
want to try another one.
So last insights
is about targeting.
Targeting matters.
Focus on your key audience.
Well, this insight may
sound a little bit obvious.
However, what is
interesting to see
is that this is not always true.
And it really depends on the
metric that you want to drive.
So if you want to
drive installs,
that is definitely the case.
So the creator, which had the
audience with a demographic
that matches as much as possible
the demographic of the game
itself, those
videos are the ones
who have the highest
install per view rates.
However, if you want
to [INAUDIBLE] trends,
this is not always
the case, because what
we saw from the data
is that, on average,
users between 24
and 49 years old
are 3x more likely to
spend than younger users.
And by the way, when
they predict spend,
they have on average a
30% higher average revenue
per paying user.
So next time you do
a campaign, think
about what you want to drive.
If you want to drive installs,
then definitely focus
on your key audience.
If you want to
drive spend, focus
on the users between
24 and 49, because they
are more likely to buy.
And when they buy,
they spend more.
So let me now pass
it over to Toby
to talk about the insights
on the influencers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOBIAS KNOKE: Thank
you, Francesco.
And he's actually not the
best FIFA player on our team.
So that's something else.
OK.
So I will now talk a
bit about the insights
we have gathered when it
comes to the influencers,
because Francesco and I did not
only look at influencer videos.
We also talked to
many developers
to understand a
bit better how they
are working with influencers.
And one thing we have
been hearing pretty often
is that once a developer
is finding an influencer
to work with, the developer
likes to work with them again
and again.
Well, this is
something you can do.
But we also saw an effect you
might want to be aware of.
And this is something what
we call download fatigue,
because if you work
with the same creator
again within the time
period of a year,
the second video will have
on average 2x less installs
compared to the first video.
So you can draw the
conclusion that gamers
who will see the first
video of a specific creator
will either convert or not.
And you still might want to work
again with the same creator,
because maybe you want to
work with them to build
your community, to
re-engage users,
or there was just a good deal.
But this is something
to be aware of.
Secondly, when we were
talking to developers,
we were discussing so
what is the performance
of these influencer
marketing campaigns.
We looked at all the
data we have gathered.
And one major thing we found out
is that many people out there
try to measure influencer
campaigns just as the same way
as they measure app
install campaigns.
I would be a little
bit cautious here,
because, one, app
install campaigns are,
if you run them on the classic
performance marketing network,
a bit different if you
only look at the setup.
If you work with
an influencer, you
need to find the
right influencer.
You need to
communicate with them.
You need to agree
on a payment model.
And if you run ads with Google
UAC or any other network,
you basically have a creative,
the bidding, and a budget,
and that's it.
And furthermore, if you look at
influencer marketing campaigns
based on traditional
performance marketing KPIs,
they might not perform as strong
as the average UAC, Facebook,
or whatever campaign.
So that is important to notice.
But there's one more
thing to be aware of.
So one, there's more
with influencers
than just performance.
And I will tell more
about this very soon.
And then, thirdly, we
also found a segment,
which was highly
profitable and very strong
when it comes to
influencer marketing.
And those were rather
small influencers,
what we call micro influencers.
So when we were looking at
smaller influencers with 10
to 100,000 subscribers,
well, these creators
were able to drive CPIs which
were on average 3x lower
than established influencers.
And also the
conversion rate, which
means the view to download,
was very strong as well.
Well, I'm now not saying
go away from the big names,
because they have some obvious
advantages, such as a higher
virality and so on and so forth.
But if you are still not sure
about influencer marketing,
you know remember when
Francesco asked all of you
at the very beginning,
maybe working
with smaller influencers could
be a nice and less risky way,
a good entry point to use
this tool for acquiring users.
So much for working
with micro influencers.
This is a summary now of
all the research we have
been doing over the past month.
And feel free to share
all these lessons
learned across your
company with product folks,
with marketing folks, with
game analytical folks,
because I think it's
important that every function
of your company is
aware of these effects.
And then you can make
the best out of it
for your specific case.
So we talked about the installs,
the nontracked majority.
We talked about ripple effects,
that targeting is important.
There's also a download fatigue.
Influencer campaigns need to
be measured a bit differently
probably than traditional
performance marketing
campaigns.
And there's a strong
potential when
it comes to micro influencers.
So what's next?
What's now?
Last but not least, I would like
to work with you on building
now an influencer
strategy, because for you
the big question is now, I've
listened to all this research.
What shall I do now when I'm
at my desk tomorrow morning
or on Monday morning?
So Francesco and I
thought about this.
And we were thinking, OK, so
maybe if you attend Playtime,
you'll go back to
your office and you
talk to your marketing
person or maybe
you're a marketing
person yourself.
And not to use any
stereotypes here
but the average performance
marketing person
might look a bit like this.
So let's say you go back to the
office and talk to him or her.
What will you say?
Well, our idea
would be tell them
about the golden rules
for influencer marketing,
because what we did is we
took all these lessons learned
and we now have a recommendation
for each of these effects.
And this is one thing
you can take home
with or take to the office.
I'm not sure what you
want to do at home.
But you can take these
lessons learned with you
and apply them in
your daily business.
So one, consider the
multipliers, the 4x,
the nontracked majority when
you evaluate your influencer
marketing campaigns.
Two.
Be aware of the ripple effects.
And be also aware that
users might download
a similar game which is
not from you but maybe
from a competitor.
So this is something
to be aware of.
And again, if you're not
too sure about influencer
marketing, maybe
wait until you have
a similar game in your portfolio
so you can finally benefit
a bit from that ripple effect.
Then thirdly, stick to the
targeting of your key audience.
And stick to the targeting of
users between 24 and 49 years.
When it comes to
download fatigue,
just be aware that
the first video
is the video which is
generating all these installs.
And if you engage
again with a creator,
it will be about re-engagement.
And when it comes to
influencer campaigns,
well, our thinking is, one, try
to be very performance based.
Try to have CPI or even revenue
share deals with influencers.
Try to go away from
those CPM deals.
Obviously, this
is always a thing
to negotiate for and with.
And there are
different strategies.
But this is at least
one thing you can do.
And then also you can
hedge against the risk
that maybe some users
who come to your game
after watching a video
of an influencer,
that these users do
not convert and pay.
Well, if you have
ads in your game,
you can hedge against this
risk, because every install
can mean a person
who is watching
an ad, a rewarded video.
And then last but not least
for the micro influencers,
we think that there is
a real opportunity here.
Do not only focus
on the big names.
And that's why we
thought, let's give you
also some best practices for
working with micro influencers.
And again, there are
many more best practices
but this is just
something to start with.
So one, the one
thing is how do you
find those people who could
be interested in your game?
Well, one very simple
idea is just go on YouTube
and check out who is
streaming your game already.
Maybe they know
other influencers.
Maybe they have subscribed
to some channels.
Try to dig into this topic.
Try to really find
those people who
would be genuinely
interested in your game,
because if these guys grow,
your game will grow with them.
Secondly, it's a good
bargaining position for you
if somebody is not
as established.
So you can try to
make good deals.
You should always do fair
deals, because there's always
karma involved in
the gaming industry.
But there is definitely a good
bargaining power on your side.
And then third, if this
was working for you,
think of scaling up.
Think of working with
several micro influencers
at the same time.
And if you think this holds
out, all good, but I do not
have so much time
for this, maybe
consider working with an
agency or a third party which
really knows this stuff.
And you can now use all the
lessons learned from today
to evaluate and brief
these third parties so you
can be sure that they deliver
the results you're looking for.
So so much for the performance
marketeer in yourself
or in your company.
But we thought there is
a bit more to influencers
than just performance.
So when you go back
to your company,
maybe do not only talk
to the marketing person.
Maybe also talk
to the guy or girl
who is looking into
social media and PR.
And again, not to use
any stereotypes here,
but that person might
look a bit like this.
So the important thing is
that community building
can help you to drive
performance in the long term.
And that's why you should
empower this person as much
as the marketeer in your team.
And why?
Because communities
can help you to be
successful in the long term.
And we tried to come
up with a formula
because we're here at Google
to explain why that is.
So one, there is
the rising quality
of new releases out there.
There are increasing
marketing costs.
And there are more and
more multiplayer games
getting released.
And that means these
users are occupied
by other games already.
So it's just getting
more competitive, right?
And that means there's a need
for creating a community,
because only if you
create a community
you will be able to survive with
your game for more than three,
four, or five years.
And creating
communities, well, this
is all what
influencers are about.
So do not only think of the
performance marketing aspect.
Do also think of the
long term benefits
of working with influencers
and opinion leaders.
And I would like to
show you now one example
of a developer who has
worked with an influencer
to build a community even ahead
of the release of the game.
Space Ape Games invited
Team Secret to their office
to play the new game "Rumble
League," which has not even
been released yet.
So let's see how it
looks like if there
is a tournament between the
developer and any sports team.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is the match you
have been waiting for.
Team Secret versus the
hometown heroes, the Space Ape
developers.
For the match of a
lifetime, coming to you
live from the Space Ape
eSports arena/kitchen.
Are you ready?
Here we go!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
TOBIAS KNOKE: Very cool.
Very cool.
So I think this
is a great example
of building a community
even if your game has not
been released yet.
The influencers are
playing directly
against the developers.
They create bonds.
They will reach out
again and again.
And this is a very,
very strong way
to be successful
in the long term.
And that also leads
me to my conclusion.
The idea is to not only
think of performance,
but also to think
of performance,
but just add this thinking that
videos and influencers are more
and ideally get the
performance marketing
person and the
social media person
together, or maybe have
a job description which
is combining both jobs.
If you're a smaller company,
you have those already.
So this is the idea of driving
success with influencers.
I would like to conclude
now this presentation
by coming back to Yarn.
You remember him?
That was the influencer
Francesco introduced to you
at the very beginning.
He has a channel
called OJ Gaming
with one million subscribers.
So he definitely knows something
about building communities.
But now I wonder
what he actually
thinks of today's presentation.
Let's hear it from himself.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Toby, Francesco, that was
an excellent presentation.
Thank you for that.
I hope everyone enjoyed
the insight on influencers
on YouTube.
Me and everyone else are super
excited to be working with you
and now Playtime.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
TOBIAS KNOKE: Thank
you very much.
And if you were not convinced
that building communities
and engaging users
makes sense, well now
this was the reason
why it is important.
This person just engaged
all of your top partners
in EMEA within 12 seconds.
If you have any more ideas,
requests, or questions,
please ask them now or also,
for more extensive questions
and ideas, please
leave your feedback
on the
g.co/play/influencervalue.
And now Francesco and myself are
happy to take a few questions
right now.
If you have any
questions, please raise
your hand and you'll get a mic.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Just a quick question for one
of the last parts you brought up
regarding using influencers
to use to build communities
pre or prior to start.
Like what was the outcome
except for the video?
TOBIAS KNOKE: I think you need
to ask Space Ape Games to get
the result of that.
But what I would personally say
is it is a long term approach,
because the outcome is
you have influencers
who then know the game.
You can be in touch with again.
And you can then
also be in touch
with the people they know.
This is just one e-sports team.
So I think this is just
a very, very small shot
of a longer term strategy
an approach which will just
help to have an organic impact
once the game is getting
released.
So let's say it's a bit like
if you're planning a big party
and you're already making
friends a few months before.
So this way the people will come
once you have the party, which
will be the launch of the game.
That's what I assume.
One more working mic.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for the awesome
presentation I think most of us
were waiting for this kind of
a thing for quite some time.
I'd like to ask you please
if you could elaborate
more of the execution itself.
So let's say I found
my pool of influencers
and I want to
execute a campaign.
What specifically would I need
to do to make use of this view
through attribution with the
windows for the Play Store
and maybe that there are maybe
some plans or strategies how
to make it more accurate.
Also for other platforms
as, of course, the traffic
would have spillover effects on
any platform where the game is.
Thank you.
TOBIAS KNOKE: So sorry.
Just the question is how to use
these insights or what exactly?
Sorry just reactivate
the mic please.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if it's just the
insights or we can use the--
TOBIAS KNOKE: OK.
Got it.
AUDIENCE: --the view
through attribution.
TOBIAS KNOKE: Got it.
AUDIENCE: --at some point.
OK.
TOBIAS KNOKE: Got it.
So today was all
about the insights,
because we are coming
from a long journey
trying to look at this topic
and helping developers.
So this is basically an
experiment and a pilot.
If you now think I
want to use this,
I want to have this
for my business,
g.co/play/influencervalue.
Please give us this
feedback, because only
if we have more ideas and
requests that you want
to use this technology
or this attribution
as part of your
business, only then
we can drive forward
with this project.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
TOBIAS KNOKE: Yes.
I think there was a question
more to front as well.
AUDIENCE: Just a
a quick question.
Is your methodology--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Here.
TOBIAS KNOKE: Hi.
Bonjour.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for the presentation.
Is your methodology
and results also
applicable to premium games?
FRANCESCO CROVETTO:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean we just had the
look at a cohort of users
watching a game and then what
do they do on the Play Store.
So that applies absolutely
to any game, free or paid
or anything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Sorry, is this on?
Yeah.
Thanks.
It's a super useful
presentation.
Quick question.
I think one of the challenges as
well is very often the referral
link on YouTube is
not very visible.
It's a bit below and all that.
Are there any plans to make that
referral link have something
a bit more powerful than that?
TOBIAS KNOKE: So we
are looking into this.
But you also know when we are
looking into things at Google
it can sometimes take a while.
But we are very, very aware
that right now the solution,
it looks like a
like a hack, right?
It looks like very,
very on the fly.
And this is still something
what we use in the industry
and which is more or less the
standard except that we now
try to look a bit beyond this.
So hopefully at some point.
That's what I think personally.
But we are looking at the space.
And again, feel free
to add this feedback.
Yes.
We are trying to
begin a movement here.
And we would be happy if
you were a part of it.
AUDIENCE: How many requests
do you need there so that we--
TOBIAS KNOKE: Yes.
Yes.
How many.
Well, there is no threshold
so we get as many as possible.
Thanks.
So one more question.
Do we have time for
one more question?
One more question?
OK.
If there are no
more questions left,
then I think we are quite
early or even on time.
That's the thing about
being in Germany.
So I am now happy to
send you off to lunch.
But before we do
that, please make
sure to check out all the games
we have in the playground.
So we have VR games,
AR games, AI games.
There is even a Google Play
quiz so you can test your Google
Play knowledge.
And you even can try your
skills in a scooter race.
So please go back
through the outdoor area
and be back for the
sessions at 2:00 PM,
because then we will
listen about monetization.
And that is something
you do not want
to miss as a game developer.
Thank you.